It's time for our pop quiz.
(bell ringing)
And guess who's been selected?
Zuleira, are you there?
(audience clapping)
Yes, I'm here.
There you are, hi.
Hi.
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh.
This is like a dream come true for me.
Oh, for us too Zuleira.
Okay, now, guess what?
If you correctly answer all three questions
about today's show, then you will win $1,000
or $100 for each question answered right.
Zuleira, are you ready?
I'm ready.
All right, let's do this.
First question.
What international holiday are we celebrating today?
The woman.
Yes, International Women's Day,
yes.
Yes.
(audience clapping)
Okay, second question, fantastic.
I don't know why I'm so nervous.
How many greens does Diane Russell's
chewable tablets contain?
Like, I don't know 50 or something?
No, okay, oh.
It's eight greens,
but another chance to win a hundred bucks.
Oh, wow.
Final question.
All right, for another $100.
What is the InStyle color of the moment?
The color potato.
Yeah, potato grande.
That is $200 for getting two answers right.
Yes.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
And guess what everybody.
Next time, our pop quiz piggy bank rolls
over to the next show.
So it will be worth $2,000.
So pay attention.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
And before we go in honor of International Women's Day,
I wanted to mention a really special initiative
that I'm proud to say Flower Beauty,
the makeup company that we started 10 years ago is a part
of CVS' beauty on altered campaign.
And its goal is to honor everyone's authenticity
and diversity.
So to celebrate being our most authentic selves
CVS is giving everyone in the audience of $50 gift card.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
And we're also giving
away this exclusive product to CVS is called color shift.
It's a lip smoothie.
That's my personal recommendation.
So you'll each be getting one of these.
And what I love about it is when you put it on your lips,
it's like a mood lip gloss.
It really enhances your own natural lip color.
So it's individual just like every woman herself.
So thank you very much
for watching everyone at home and our VFS.
Thank you, Rossy
Thank you, Drew
Thank you, we hope you have a great day.
Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)